-New text messages reveal
that even more
high-ranking Republicans
than we initially knew
were involved
in Donald Trump's attempt
to overturn the election,
including his son, Don Jr.
Also, Trump is still ranting
about windmills
and conservatives are talking
about tanning their testicles.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
With all of the major crises
we currently face --
war in Ukraine,
COVID cases rising again,
impending climate disaster,
and a widening wealth gap
with power concentrated in fewer
and fewer corporate hands --
you'd think Republicans
would have moved on
from their usual
weird obsessions.
But last week, Donald Trump
did an interview on Fox News,
and you'll never guess
what he wanted to talk about.
-Today I saw a big story
that there are very -- millions
and millions of dollars
are being charged on windmills
because they're killing eagles.
They're killing the bald eagle
and other eagles
and other birds.
And we have these windmills
all over the place,
and the environmentalists
pretend they love them,
but they're really
hurting our country.
-It's funny how certain
people want me
to stop talking
about Donald Trump,
but Donald Trump won't stop
talking about windmills.
And in my defense,
Donald Trump was president,
and windmills are just
[bleep] windmills.
[ Laughter ]
It's also very unconvincing
that he cares
for the well-being of bird life,
especially when he pronounces
"eagle" like that.
with the emphasis
on the first letter,
Does he think it's like email?
[As Trump] Sean, the other day
I saw an eagle
logging into his email,
smoking an e-cigarette,
and I'll tell you
it's destroying our country.
[Normal voice]
Now, of course, it is unfair
to just play a clip of Trump
from an interview
without also playing
the question that prompted it.
I'm sure his "windmills are
Freddy Krueger, but for birds"
answer makes more sense
in context.
Let's give it a listen.
-Most economists now say
this is going to turn
into a full-blown recession,
and maybe worse.
What do you see
if he doesn't change course?
-So, of course, it had nothing
to do with windmills.
[ Laughter ]
What was I expecting?
What possible question
could've justified that answer?
"Sir, I'd like to get
your thoughts
on our treasured
avian population
and various threats
to their survival,
including new forms of energy
dependent on wind.
If possible, start with
a big story you saw today,
and should you mention eagles,
do feel free
to pronounce it weird."
-Today I saw a big story
that there are very -- millions
and millions of dollars
are being charged on windmills
because they're killing eagles.
-And you want Trump to comment
on Biden changing course?
Trump has never changed
course in his life.
That's why he's obsessed
with windmills.
He just goes around in circles
and makes a giant sucking sound.
But say what you will
about the guy --
he's always laser-focused
on his grudges,
whether it's windmills or
the Democrats investigating him.
Yesterday, Trump,
devout Christian that he is,
issued an Easter message
that said in part,
"Happy Easter to all, including
the Radical Left Maniacs
who are doing everything
possible to destroy our Country.
May they not succeed,
but let them, nevertheless,
be happy, healthy,
wealthy, and well!"
Now, in fairness --
in fairness,
he is quoting the Bible there.
Who can forget when Jesus said
unto his disciples,
"Blessed are the meek, for they
shall inherit the earth,
except of course,
for the meek birds
whose heads I'm takin' off
with a windmill blade"?
[ Laughter ]
Also, just a side note here,
but Radical Left Maniacs
is a great band name.
I'm pretty sure I saw them
at the Warped Tour in 1995.
They were kind of like
the Mighty Mighty Bosstones,
or at least that's
the impression that I got.
[ Light laughter ]
And that was today's
Joke for Ska Fans.
[ Laughter ]
We just have to -- I'm just
saying, when we do it,
like, just let's try to invite
ska fans that day.
[ Laughter ]
You know what I mean?
Like let's send --
when the email goes out
for tickets,
if it's going to be
ska joke day,
like, let's just try
to pack the house a little.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause I'm out here [bleep]
you know, risking it.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm getting nothing back.
And look,
I look forward to ska day
as much as anybody!
But if we're not going to do
any, like, audience maintenance
on ska day...
[ Laughter ]
And yet, still, none of that was
the pettiest or weirdest thing
to happen in right-wing politics
this week,
because it was all outdone when
Fox News host Tucker Carlson
previewed a new episode
for Fox's streaming service,
where he expressed concern
that, among other things,
testosterone levels among men
were declining, and interviewed
a guest who proposed
an interesting solution.
-If you want to optimize
and take it to another level,
expose yourself
to red light therapy.
-Yes.
-And the Joovv
that we were using
in the documentary,
there's a massive amount of --
-Which is testicle tanning.
-It's testicle tanning,
but it's also full-body
red light therapy,
which has massive
amount of benefits.
And there's so much data
out there
that isn't being picked up on
or covered.
-So, obviously, half the viewers
right now are like, "What?
That's -- testicle tanning?
That's crazy!"
But my view is, okay,
testosterone levels crash
and nobody says anything
about it -- that's crazy.
So, why is it crazy
to seek solutions?
-It's not!
Clearly, Donald Trump
has already tried it.
I also...
[ Laughter ]
I also like that Tucker says
half of his viewers will think
testicle tanning is crazy.
I'm going to go out on a limb
and say that if you're tuning in
to watch
a Tucker Carlson special
on Fox's streaming service
titled "The End of Men,"
you might be down to clown
with just about anything.
I would venture
half his audience was saying,
"I have to try that,"
and the other half
was saying, "Testicle tanning?
Tell me something I don't know.
I suppose my nuts
to red light therapy every day.
Sometimes I just drop 'em
straight into the toaster
and let them warm up
for a few sec.
And, you know, if you really
want to be an alpha man,
you just got to stick your
entire junk in the microwave
and put it on popcorn mode.
That's just
when you're advanced."
It's so insane, even Kid Rock,
who for some reason
was a guest on this special
or whatever it was,
couldn't wrap
his head around it.
-Dude, stop.
Testicle tanning? Come on.
[ Laughs ]
I mean...
-Yeah, yeah.
-I haven't heard anything
that good in a long time.
-Open your mind, Bobby!
Don't you think at this point,
when so many of the therapies,
the paths they've told us
to take
have turned out to be dead ends
that have really hurt people,
why wouldn't open-minded people
seek new solutions?
-I-I don't know what the hell's
going on in this world.
I'm not even sure
if I understood that question.
[ Laughter ]
-Well...
When you've lost Kid Rock...
[ Laughter ]
The best part is they laugh
about it like it's a joke,
but then Tucker doubles down
and says,
"No, seriously,
why not consider it?"
Hell, why stop
at red light therapy?
Maybe in addition to light,
your testicles need air,
which we could generate using...
-Windmills.
-And...
[ Laughter ]
Also, even if there was
some sort of massive
global testosterone crisis,
is it already time to resort
to tanning your balls?
Nothing is crazier than
a conservative's second idea.
"I don't trust vaccines,
but I'll eat some horse paste."
Are there ever solutions
somewhere between Plan A
and the craziest [bleep]
you've ever heard?
It's like if someone said,
"There's a bird in the house,"
and you said, "Open a window,"
and they said,
"That didn't work,"
so then you immediately jumped
to, "Okay, in that case,
dress like a bird and slowly
perform a romantic courtship
with the bird in your home.
When you win its trust,
invite them to
a romantic evening
outside in the moonlight,
and then when they
least expect it --
whoom! -- windmill chop,
off with their head!"
The point is,
these are the people leading
the conservative movement
in the Republican Party
at a time
when it is poised to retake
power in the November midterms
and possibly renominate Trump
for president in 2024,
even as we continue to learn
more about his efforts
to overturn the last election.
For example,
newly unearthed text messages
reveal that yet another sitting
senator, Utah's Mike Lee,
was coordinating
with the White House on ways
to overturn the results,
including pitching a plan
to appoint alternate slate
of electors from swing states.
At one point in November 2020,
he texted Trump's
chief of staff, Mark Meadows...
And then, two days later,
said again...
I'm not sure it's a good idea
to go to Trump
begging to know
what you should be saying.
Trump would make a terrible
Cyrano de Bergerac.
"Cyrano, tell me
what to say to her!"
[As Trump] Tell her she's got
a butt that won't quit
and honkers to match.
[ Laughter ]
[Normal voice] And Lee wasn't
the only one in on it.
There are also new
secret text messages
from Trump's son Don Jr.
-November 5, 2022 --
two days after
the 2020 election.
Votes were still being counted,
the final outcome
still in doubt,
but President Trump's son
Don Jr.
was already passing on ideas
for overturning the election
if necessary to ensure
a second term for his father.
"It's very simple,"
Trump Jr. texted,
before outlining
several options.
"We have operational control.
Total leverage."
Trump Jr was texting White House
Chief of Staff Mark Meadows.
-I love when dummies
like Don Jr. use phrases
like "total leverage"
and "operational control."
He sounds like the bad guy
in a Jean-Claude Van Damme movie
called "Total Leverage,"
who gets thrown off a helicopter
in the first five minutes.
"We have operational control.
Hold on, someone's tapping me
on the shoulder.
Let me just turn around and --
Oh, no! Jean-Claude!"
[ Laughter ]
And he had to text
the chief of staff
instead of
going straight to his own dad.
"We are in
operational control.
Now, do you have
my father's email address?
I would like to set up
a father-son
testicle tanning appointment."
This is the state of the modern
conservative movement
as they aim to retake power.
They're focused on windmills,
testosterone levels,
overturning elections.
Just a word of advice --
I'd be careful not to do
too much testicle tanning,
or you're going to end up with
a nut sack that looks like a...
-Bald eagle.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.